usage de la force par la police samedi
soir la journée des droits de la famille
hier on en parle tout de suite avec
fatima à benomar cofondatrice de
l'association les effrontés madame
benomar bienvenue sur rt france merci
d'être avec nous en direct peut-être
programme arts question une réaction par
rapport aux violences policières de
saint-dié soir pendant la marche
féministe
ces violences étaient absolument
incompréhensible la marche est très bien
débrouillé de place des fêtes jusqu'à la
place de la république
et là j'ai vu on a vu avec les copines
un nuage de fumée de lacrymogènes c'est
là qu'on a fuit contrairement à ce qu'a
dit marlène schiappa que c'est nous qui
aurions modifier le trajet en fait on a
fui les lacrymogènes vers le boulevard
richard lenoir qui mènent nulle part on
n'avait aucun intérêt à y aller et on a
vu débarquer la bac qui a commis entre
autres toutes ces violences policières
que vous avez pu voir en images sur les
réseaux sociaux
deuxième chose on nous a dit que oui on
avait refusé enfin quand on avait essayé
de disperser en vain déjà très
franchement l'avait delà de la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes de voir un
cortège qui étaient tellement nombreux
qu'effectivement il est venu quelques
minutes en retard et de disperser par la
force
qu'est-ce qui nous empêchait tout
simplement de nous laisser terminer
notre trajet république comme c'était
prévu c'était une marche symboliquement
très importante les femmes viennent en
masse dans cette marche parce que le
reste de l'année quand elles ont peur de
sortir dans la rue de nuit elles ont
peur des violences masculines la leçon
dit qu'elle pouvait être en confiance en
force il y avait beaucoup de jeunes de
mineurs deux lycéennes et là elles se
sont coltinés d'autres formes de
violence masculine qui étaient les
violences policières et leur
démonstration de force et les
humiliations
encore une fois c'est indigne et
notamment par rapport à la thématique de
la manifestation qui est contre les
violences les féminicides les viols les
agressions sexuelles que les jeunes
femmes expérimente très jeune
autour de la puberté même avant c'est
absolument indigne qu'elle est due en
plus avoir affaire à des hommes
majoritairement dans les forces de
l'ordre qui les prennent de force et les
enfance dans le métro pour leur dire
maintenant de quitter l'espace public
alors tout le monde devrait se lever 1
pour le droit des femmes c'est un combat
pas seulement réservé aux femmes
pourtant c'est trop souvent le cas n'est
ce pas
oui c'est trop souvent le cas on parle
du coronavirus avec ces mares on a aussi
cette année depuis le 1er janvier 17
femmes qui encore une fois été tuées par
leur conjoint ou par leur ex nous tout à
fait une enquête en ligne sur le
consentement dans le couple à laquelle
cent mille personnes ont participé en
très grande majorité des jeunes femmes
parce que c'est un peu la communauté des
réseaux sociaux qui suit nous tout est
beaucoup ont témoigné de pression de
violence même dans le cadre de jeunes
couples qui se forment et donc c'est
quand même très important d'écouter
cette jeunesse qui se révolte qui était
aussi révoltée par ce qui s'est passé à
la cérémonie des césar qui voulait
relever la tête relevé le front investir
l'espace public faire une manifestation
alors c'est censé être en plus sa grande
cause nationale et qui se retrouve
encore une fois réprimées dans sa
liberté d'expression il faudrait plutôt
entendre cette jeunesse qui prend
conscience quand même apporte un combat
important c'est ce qui va leur donner de
la force plus tard et de l'énergie quand
elles vont se coltiner des violences ou
bien conjugale ou bien dans le milieu de
travail pour hausser le ton et ne pas se
laisser faire et on est en train de les
mater dès le plus jeune âge et de leur
dire qu'elles n'ont pas parlé beaucoup
d'injustice en inégalités dans les
entreprises violences faites aux femmes
féminisme les chiffres sont d'ailleurs
assez effrayant aujourd'hui en france
quelle est selon vous la priorité
la priorité c'est de sécuriser le
parcours des femmes quand elles veulent
quitter leur conjoint violent quand
elles veulent porter plainte
on sait très bien que les procès par
exemple pour viol quand il n'y a pas de
preuve formelle c'est à dire une caméra
de surveillance ou quoi que ce soit
c'est un vrai massacre pour les femmes
on va leur poser sans fois les mêmes
questions sur les détails pour essayer
de trouver la faille dans le récit on va
essayer d attaquer dans leur réputation
dans leur crédibilité
elles sont toujours pas prises au
sérieux dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries
il ya toujours des classements sans
suite en masse on est dans un système
judiciaire où on estime à 1 % des
violeurs condamnés
c'est même pas c'est pas 30% c'est pas
20% c'est important donc c'est un
système complètement inefficients donc
il faut l'adapter à la réalité de ces
violences et puis dans les mondes de
pouvoir la politique le cinéma on l'a vu
il faut casser cette idée des artistes
qui sont qui ont les pleins pouvoirs
les cinéastes qui peut faire ce qu'il
veut de la jeune actrice dans les
tournages les photographes que ce soit
polanski au hamilton qui pensent que
parce qu'une mineure une fillette est là
et qu'ils doivent d'être dirigés pour
les photographier ils peuvent du coup
les violé parce qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'elles sont à leur disposition et
c'est pour ça qu'on était très en colère
pendant les césar on a redécoré cet
homme qui admet que pendant qu'ils
photographier une gamine de 13 ans je
parle de polanski il en a profité pour
lui servir de l'alcool de la drogue et
la violer donc c'est important de
remettre en cause tous ces systèmes qui
organise l'impunité des agresseurs ce
soit parce qu'ils ont un statut
d'artiste ou de patrons ou quoi que ce
soit ou de mari fatima benomar merci je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondatrice de
l'association les effrontés merci
d'avoir et en direct avec